for years after its release The Witcher
3 Wild Hunt remains one of the most
technically impressive games of this
generation so to see it running on a
Nintendo switch seems too good to be
true but unsurprisingly there is a big
trade-off here the textures are muddy
the draw distances are poor and the
framerate is less than ideal however if
you can overlook the ports technical
shortcomings there is something very
enticing about taking one of 2015's best
games on the go over the course of my to
our demo I explored Velan 2 song care
more on white orchard Skellig ax and
novigrad what surprised me the most was
how consistent ran between all those
areas when The Witcher 3 launched in
2015 the swamps in Velan and the denser
streets in novigrad were notorious for
causing wild swings and performance
console players were especially
susceptible to low frame rates and
stutters while exploring these areas
however based on what I played the
switch version seems to handle those
areas about as well as it does the other
regions that being said don't confuse
consistency with good performance if you
are looking for a buttery smooth
gameplay experience and the portability
doesn't interest you then you might want
to start a new save on PC these
technical limitations shouldn't come as
a surprise since the Nintendo switch is
running off a custom mobile CPU and GPU
but if you've played The Witcher 3 on PC
Xbox one or ps4 recently it can be a
little jarring to look at in this
diminished form handheld the game hits
around 25 frames a second at 5:40 P
while docked it comes in around 720p
however the resolution is dynamic
meaning that it can change depending on
what's on the screen if you are used to
playing on the standard ps4 or Xbox one
these lower frame rates may not be a
huge issue PC ps4 pro and Xbox one X
users on the other hand might have a
tougher time getting used to the
movement in combat once my eyes adjusted
to the lower frame rate and resolution
it felt like I was playing The Witcher 3
and that is a very good thing GameSpot
gave the witcher 3 a 10 out of 10 back
in 2015 for its top-notch riding and
absorbing world if you haven't gotten
around to playing it this might be the
perfect opportunity so what do you think
do you plan on replaying The Witcher 3
on switch I'm gonna let the gameplay run
for just a bit longer so you can get
more of an idea of how the port looks
just keep in mind that the audio is a
bit funky and that's due to our capture
equipment not the game itself
I wanna decide this yet again
looking for a woman uh like everyone not
like everyone and not just any woman
mine smells of lilac and gooseberries
dresses in black and white to snap seize
it'll lift your spirits fine I'll have a
drink
can we cut to the chase you seen her or
not
yennefer of vengerberg never mentioned
her name yet you described her perfectly
once I hear something I never forget
come here
you